choosing someone to take over a role
from another actor is never easy
especially when the original actor Drew
praise for their take on a character but
recasting is often an unavoidable fact
of filmmaking especially for sequels and
remakes whether it's creative
disagreements Financial setbacks or
simple timing issues at hand actors
often become unavailable to resume their
roles and must be replaced sometimes the
newcomer can blend right into the
Blockbuster scene unnoticed but in the
case of these casting switcheroos the
change was just too drastic for
audiences to endure
Clarice Starling when director Ridley
Scott signed on to direct The Silence of
the Lamb sequel he did so without his
Clarice Starling in place Anthony
Hopkins had already negotiated a return
to the role of Hannibal leor but jod
Foster didn't share his enthusiasm for
the second chapter in the serial killer
story despite winning an Oscar for the
role in the first film she later told
total film the official reason I didn't
do Hannibal is I was doing another movie
Flora Plum so I get to say in a nice
dignified way way that I wasn't
available when that movie was being shot
but Clarice meant so much to Lamb's
director Jonathan Demi and I there was
no way that either of us could really
trample on her now that's really
interesting
Clarice I'm really pressed for time
several bigname actresses were
considered to take her place and the
part ultimately went to Julianne Moore
while both Scott and Hopkins were happy
with the choice audiences weren't as
convinced more was inevitably compared
to Foster and couldn't measure up to her
predecessor screen Savvy nor rekindle
the creepy connection Clarice had shared
with Hopkins in the first film jod
Foster offered her own diplomatic but
Shady take on the film saying simply I
saw Hannibal I won't comment Evelyn
oconnell The Mummy was a surprise smash
for Universal posting Global receipts of
$415 million and landing on the top 10
highest grossing films in 1999 it
launched Brendan Frasier's career as a
Hollywood action hero and introduced the
world to a stunning new Leading Lady and
Rachel Vice the pair made a compelling
onscreen couple and reprised their roles
in The Mummy Returns which managed to
bring in a nice haul from the box office
as well but by the time the third film
came around Vice was suffering from some
serious mummy fatigue and stepped aside
Vice was rumored to call the script for
The Mummy 3 crap so the studio turned to
Maria Bellow to fill in for the role
that should give us a good Advantage
unfortunately for Bella her turn in the
role was criticized for lacking the
charm of the original and the film
failed to recoup its production cost in
the domestic box
office why am I
laughing the genie the90s marked a
moment of resurgence for Disney's
animated film collection with films like
Beauty and the Beast and the Lion King
offering a new generation of children
some cartoon movies to sing along to one
of Disney's most beloved films of the
era was Aladdin an Oscar winning take on
the Arabic folk tale about the street
Thief who sheds his rags and won the
heart of a princess Aladdin was packed
full of great musical numbers but the
the main reason it became such a smash
was the input of the late Robin Williams
as the genie it's all part and partial
the whole Genie gig phenomenal cosic
po the actor confirmed that he wouldn't
be lending his voice to the direct of
video sequel The Return of Jafar after
an alleged row with Disney over its
marketing tactics so the search for a
new Genie began Dan cast Letta the
legendary voice of Homer Simpson was
ultimately chosen to voice the big blue
guy but the Simpson star just couldn't
measure up to Williams frenetic
performance the quality of the animation
didn't help matters but cast Lanetta
lacked the unpredictability that
Williams brought to the genie
essentially doing a water down
impression of his predecessor
don't Jack Ryan there are five films
based on Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan books
but only one actor has played the
protagonist twice eyebrows were raised
when Alec Baldwin was given the boot
after he successfully debuted Ryan on
screen in The Hunt for Red October
Baldwin later implied that the studio
had gone behind his back and entered
into negotiations with Ford to take the
role of Ryan well that was a guess but
it seemed logical even so Ford's
performance in Patriot Games and clear
and present danger became definitive for
the character 8 years later another
actor stepped in to bring a much younger
version of Jack Ryan to the big screen
this time it was Ben Affleck who stepped
in for the sum of all fears his
performance in the role was met with
disdain however and the Jack Ryan
franchise never really recovered after
that despite an attempt to reboot it
with Chris Pine in the lead role more
than a decade later Sarah Connor
following in the footsteps of Linda
Hamilton as Sarah Connor in The
Terminator franchise was never going to
be easy for any actress Hamilton gave a
performance so layered and compelling
that even the most talented performers
have struggled to do the character
Justice the first to give it a shot was
Lena H who was cast in the role in the
short-lived TV series Terminator the
Sarah Connor Chronicles Fox canceled the
show after two seasons citing its high
cost as a reason but H's Game of Thrones
colleague Amelia Clark was willing to
give it another go on the Silver Screen
for Terminator Genesis the film was a
box office dud and was heavily
criticized for using the old time travel
Chestnut to rewrite the beginning of the
Terminator story to suit the filmmaker's
purposes the main problem wasn't the
infuriatingly muddled timeline though it
was the casting as much as TV lovers
might dig Clark's portrayal of Daenerys
Targaryen and Game of Thrones the film
crowd was decidedly not well by her run
as Sarah Connor where her line
deliveries packed a lot less punch than
the original come with me if you want to
live pass Van Wilder National Lampoon
Van Wilder isn't going to be preserved
in the Library of Congress National film
registry anytime soon yet for all of its
failings fans of a certain age remember
this movie fondly this was a time when
frat humor was at its peak and sitting
down to watch a comedy usually meant
turning your brain off for 90 minutes
Van Wilder might not have been the most
cerebral comedy of all time but Ryan
Reynolds still delivered as the fast
talk and cool guy who threw the best
parties and was a softy underneath all
those crazy Antics after the Cal pen Le
sequel was destroyed by critics The
Producers decided their next move was a
prequel featuring a younger version of
Van Wilder so they brought in Mean Girls
Jonathan Bennett for Van Wilder freshman
year which was a terrible mistake I have
never seen such a sorry display in all
my life the actor couldn't come close to
the Charisma of his predecessor and
produced a featurelength failed
impression effort as a result Willie
Maye Hayes Major League was a surprise
Grand Slam for Paramount Pictures and
produced two increasingly terrible
sequels and while Charlie Sheen's Wild
Thing came back for a second round at
the mound in Major League 2 there was
another standout actor from the first
film who refused to run the bases of
this franchise again Wesley Snipes whose
Charming Swagger as the Speedy base
Thief was a home run in the first movie
had no interest in returning to the
Dugout for the second movie at the time
he was well on his way to becoming a
Hollywood MVP in his own right thanks to
movies like White Men Can't Jump and
Demolition Man so he pretty much priced
himself out of the second movie with the
Cleveland Indians down a man on their
roster the filmmakers turned to relative
newcomer Omar EPS to sub in as a pinch
runner for the project unfortunately EPS
didn't have a strong background in
comedy and his performance was the
Cinematic equivalent of a foul ball read
some of your reviews man one guy said
Willie May Hayes couldn't play
just a bit outside Albus Dumbledore the
prisoner of aaban might still be a
favorite among some Harry Potter fans
thanks to the arrival of Sirius Black
and that wild wiing Willow but the fact
remains that it's the lowest grossing
movie in the franchise and for many the
subdued enthusiasm seems to stem from
the unfortunate arrival of a new
Hogwarts Headmaster in the film Richard
Harris's take on Albus Dumbledore in the
first two movies had become definitive
for Potter fans so in the actor died
after a battle with Hotchkins disease
the filmmakers had to turn to another
actor to step into the Beloved
professor's cloak Michael Gambon seemed
like a fine choice to conjure up for the
franchise but his performance in his
first run as Dumbledore was stunted by
the fact that he never read the books
rather than resuming Harris's
spellbindingly calm and wise demeanor
gamon delivered a much more Stern and
aggressive version of the character for
his first few outings you put your name
in a cou of the
fire yes one of the old the students to
do it for you no sir you're absolutely
sure yes gamon would later summon up the
same sort of chill pill that saved the
role from being ruined for children
across the globe but these moments of
mismatching between the Beloved book
character and the screen interpretation
still cost the movies many house points
in the eyes of the true Potter
Fanatics Catwoman hi Berry taking over
Michelle Fifer's role in Catwoman is
perhaps the most infamous example of
recasting going terribly wrong DC's
leather CL glad heroin has appeared in
numerous Batman adaptations over the
years but Fifer's psychotically sexy
performance in Tim Burton's Batman
Returns Remains the cats meow I don't
know about you Miss Kitty but I feel so
much yummier the actress initially
intended to reprise the role in the solo
spin-off but after years of development
woses her patience reached its limit and
she decided to concentrate on other
commitments after a rigorous recruiting
process Barry was ultimately chosen to
climb into the catsuit and what a mess
it all was the film was a complete
disaster bombing hard at the box office
while cleaning up at the razis Barry
took her worst actress win in good humor
and even turned up to accept her award
in person Batman another error in
judgment from the Batman Universe
occurred when Michael Keaton handed over
the keys for Wayne Manor to Val Kilmer
Keaton had portrayed the role in 1989's
Batman and its equel Batman Returns but
he refused to reprise the role in a
third film after reading the screen
screenplay when pressed for details
Keaton later said that the script he was
shown sucked and that it was just awful
pointing the blame for his departure
squarely at the writers Vel Kilmer
clearly didn't share Keaton's opinion
the tombstone star accepted the role and
went into the film knowing he'd have to
contend with a wide cast of wacky
villains as well as a new director Joel
Schumacher ultimately shouldered a lot
of the blame for the Badness of Batman
Forever though his leading man didn't
Escape criticism what am
I please
you're as blind as a bat he was quickly
replaced with George Clooney and Batman
and Robin the good news for Kilmer is
that Clooney's turn as The Dark Knight
wasn't any more loved than his own and
soon everyone forgot about Kilmer's turn
in the Batmobile look at it take it
off it's Val
Kilmer oh are you an
actual most of us are used to the idea
of an actor getting a role and you know
acting the part we'll even accept a
stunt double for scenes where the actor
needs to jump out of a plane but for the
most part if we're watching Gary buy we
want to see Gary buy wait why do we want
to see Gary Bucy
again as it turns out we're not always
watching who we think we're watching and
that happens much more often than we
realize there have been plenty of times
when actors were swapped out and us in
the audience never even noticed Natalie
Portman
the heat of kiss between Thor and Jane
Foster in Thor the Dark world's post
credit scene is one of the steamiest
moments in all the Marvel movies and
with good reason actor Chris Hemsworth
isn't making out with his co-star
Natalie Portman the scene was shot after
principal photography had wrapped and
Natalie Portman was unavailable Portman
told the New York daily news I couldn't
get there because I was working on my
own film and so they put his wife in my
wig and costume that's why it was so
passionate yep himsworth was locking
lips with his real real life wife
Spanish actress and Fast and Furious
star Elsa Pataki the switch Sho
certainly saved a lot of trouble for the
crew while filming other kissing scenes
in the Thor series Portman said that
since she's so short they usually had a
ramp for me to walk up so I could land
somewhere near his face because that's
the only way to make this turn into
something like this Bruce Lee after
Bruce Le's untimely death on July 20th
1973 one of his greatest passion
projects was left UNF finished Game of
Death of which Lee had already filmed
about 40 minutes 5 years later director
Robert clouse picked up the pieces and
was forced to create a brand new plot
using Lee's previously filmed scenes
shots from older Bruce Lee projects and
even footage from Lee's real life
funeral in addition to archival film
clouse also hired standin to play Billy
low Lee's character in the new version
of Game of Death in K clouse's Game of
Death low both receives plastic surgery
after a brutal fight and later fakes his
own death and wears a disguise making it
easy for clouse to replace Lee with
other actors although some parts weren't
exactly seamless will sitting right
there by the
telephone just waiting for you to call
with patience that's not one of our
virtues Michael pit it's hard to imagine
anyone more villainous than Hannibal
Lecter but the TV series Hannibal gave
us just such character in Mason virger
as the sadistic meat packing Tycoon
Boardwalk Empire star Michael pit spends
the latter half of the show's second
season tormenting the other characters
pit delivers a terrifying performances
virger who showrunner Brian Fuller
called The Joker to Hannibal's Batman
but while Mason Verger returned in
season 3 Michael pit didn't Joe Anderson
took over the role and had to spend the
entirety of the Season covered in heavy
Prosthetics fortunately Anderson's vocal
performance was Flawless resulting in a
seamless transition between the two
actors
now I can talk face to
face Nicholas Brendan Nicholas Brendan
appeared in all but one episode of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer and yet surprisingly
he wasn't the only person to play Xander
Harris Buffy's geeky pal and perennial
punching bag Brendan's twin brother who
uses the stage name Kelly Donovan often
took Brendan's place when the actor
wasn't available or when Buffy's
Supernatural Shenanigans required more
than one X Ander on screen at once
Donovan made his most memorable
appearance on Buffy in the fifth season
episode the replacement in which a demon
creates a second Xander who threatens to
take over the original's life in the
episode intervention Donovan replaced
Brendan entirely during some action
scenes when Brendan had amonia and
couldn't come to the set Jean Hackman it
might be hard to imagine now but in the
70s only one big budget superhero
franchise ruled the Silver Screen even
before the first Superman film became a
breakout hit director Richard Donner was
already working on a sequel
unfortunately during filming Donner
clashed with producers Ilia and
Alexander sine about the film's budget
and although Donner had filmed roughly
75% of Superman 2 during production of
the first film he was replaced by a hard
days nights Richard Lester in order to
secure a director's credit Lester reshot
quite a bit of Donner's footage
substantially changing Superman 2's
story and tone the process the way the
sukin treated Donner didn't set well
with the cast reportedly Christopher
reev was openly Furious about Donner's
dismissal according to the book Superman
versus Hollywood Jean Hackman who played
Lex Luthor in both films flat out
refused to show up to finish shooting
Superman 2 with Hackman absent Lester
and the suin were forced to use body
doubles and voice impersonators just to
finish the movie Josh pence in 2010 Army
Hammer made headlin and picked up a
couple of awards for his portrayal of
identical twins Cameron and Tyler winlos
in the social network but he couldn't
have done it alone on the set Tyler was
actually played by Gangster Squad star
Josh Pence later Pence's face was
digitally replaced with hammers by the
special effects team in order to prepare
for the Dual roles hammer and Pence
attended a twin boot camp where together
they worked out each twin brother's
particular quirks and mannerisms and
while pin's career hasn't taken off like
him
he's become more positive about his
social network experience over time Josh
Dallas for such a small role Marvel
studi sure had a lot of trouble casting
fandel The Dashing the Asgardian Warrior
first chuckar Zachary Levi was set to
play the goatee to Guardian but had to
drop out when NBC ordered more episodes
of Chuck's third season next Marvel cast
Queen of the dam star steuart Townsen in
the role but Townsen departed shortly
before filming due to mysterious
creative differences Marvel eventually
found its foundr and a then unknown
actor named Josh Dallas who finally
brought the classic character to the
screen but the trouble didn't stop there
between Thor's Premiere and the start of
filming on Thor the Dark World Dallas
landed the role of Prince Charming on
ABC's fairy tale drama Once Upon a Time
because of Once Upon a Time's rigorous
shooting schedule Dallas couldn't join
his fellow Warriors for their big screen
return and Marvel needed to recast the
part their choice Zachary Levi of course
who was finally free to take the roll
perhaps next time we should start with
the big one Penelope crw Monica Cruz had
been an accomplished dancer and actress
for years and while she's had featured
roles in several foreign movies she's
probably most famous in America for her
part in Pirates of the Caribbean on
Stranger Tides in which she played her
sister Penelope Penelope took over from
Kira nly and Rob Marshall's 2010 Sequel
and played the part of Angelica Jack
Sparrow's love interest while filming
though Penelope learned that she was
pregnant in order to minimize the risk
to Penelope's unborn baby Marshall hired
Monica who looks a lot like her older
sister to serve as a stand in in an
interview with the telegraph Penelope
said I did a couple of months of
training and did what I was able to do
but I couldn't do everything just what
was safe Monica came at the end to do
some scenes she's a dancer and very good
with the sword because she's done a film
herself neither Penelope nor Monica
returned in Pirates of the Caribbean
Dead Men tell no Tales but the Cru
family is still a big part of the
franchise
Javier bardam Penelope's husband plays
the film's lead villain Lena HTI as
Cersei Lannister Lena Hy plays the
ultimate villain on HBO's Game of
Thrones so viewers watched with a bit of
sadistic Glee when the character was
literally and figuratively dressed down
and then paraded through the streets of
King's Landing in nothing but smears of
Filth the scene is intense and
humiliating and drawn out so the
audience can experience her awkward
humiliation the craziest part however is
that we're not even watching H in the
scene the entire walk is performed by a
body devil seamlessly merged with H's
facial expressions and body language to
make one awkward horrible walk to the
red keep Brandon Lee The Son of
legendary Marshall artist Bruce Lee the
Charming and talented Brandon Lee was
set to take Hollywood by storm sadly
while filming his breakout role in The
Crow Lee was shot by a prop gun that had
a dummy round left in the chamber he
died later at the hospital to complete
the film Lee's friend and stunt double
Chad stahelski stood in for him while
special effects were used to give him
Lee's face meanwhile another stunt
double helped finish out some of the
action scenes the result is a movie in
which Lee's role is perfect and there's
no indication of the tragedy that befell
him Jennifer Aniston friends was a
massive success and Jennifer Aniston is
arguably the biggest star It produced
which makes it all the more unusual that
it took years after the show was off the
air for someone to finally notice an
episode where Aniston inexplicably
disappears a fan watching a friend's
Marathon happened to notice a strange
scene in the one with the mugging from
the ninth season Aniston is standing
next to Matt LeBlanc except it's not
Aniston at all it seems that Aniston
standin was on the set that day and for
whatever reason her scene wasn't edited
to remover from the shot the presence of
a standin isn't such a crazy thing after
all stand-ins are on set to replace
actors when they're not available it's
just that they usually don't end up in
the Final Cut Shimp Howard The Three
Stooges were under contract to produce
eight films in 1956 unfortunately four
films into their contract shm Howard
died of a heart attack at age 60 and in
the 1950s no one gave a damn if you died
or not your contract needed to be
fulfilled and thus was born the fake shm
producer Jules white said about
producing four brand new films each
starring shm by cutting together old
footage with new scenes featuring Joel
Palma an actor who had long fil build
supporting roles in the stous films they
just filmed him from behind or with his
face obscured hey Chef we're in here we
got a lot of work to do so shake a leg
hold your horses will you the deception
was so obvious that its Legacy still
lives on today the cast of evil dad the
term fake Shimp was actually coined by
director Sam Ry because he needed to use
quite a few of them during production of
evil dead as star Bruce Campbell
recounted in his Memoir if chins could
kill because the film was so Ultra
lowbudget Remy and the actors couldn't
always work on the same schedule Remy
needed to film what he could when he
could and with whom he could this meant
no fewer than 18 stand-ins were used
during production that's pretty
incredible as the end result shows no
sign that so many extra people were
involved even though the film is still
notoriously
ridiculous shut
up
Harrison Ford on the set of Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom Harrison
Ford suffered a pretty severe back
injury that sidelined him for several
weeks of filming Steven Spielberg
however was prepared for any eventuality
Ford was swapped with his longtime stunt
double Vic Armstrong Armstrong acted so
much like Ford that he managed to
confuse Spielberg on set more than once
a number of action scenes were filmed
with for including the epic fight
between Indie and the massive Warrior on
the Mind conveyor
belt choosing the perfect actor for a
movie role is already a delicate process
but it becomes even more difficult when
an actor leaves a production which can
happen for any number of reasons
directors and casting professionals can
be left scrambling to replace their
departing Stars here are some of the
craziest last minute Replacements we've
seen on the big screen some of which
ended up being the replacement actor's
most successful role Mike Myers and
Shrek it's hard to imagine anything but
Mike Myers voice coming from The Lovable
animated ogre but the story of Shrek's
casting is actually quite tragic
originally comedian and character actor
Chris Farley had been cast in the role
and according to his brother Kevin
Farley actually completed recording
nearly all of his dialogue for the
original Shrek film people see me and
they
go help a big stupid stinky smelly ugly
ogre unfortunately Farley had been
struggling for some time with alcohol
and substance abuse and in December 1997
he passed away in his Chicago apartment
after an accidental drug overdose
DreamWorks rushed to find a replacement
and chose Meyers additionally they
recast the role of Fiona with Cameron
Diaz who replac Farley's SNL castmate
Janine garao Christian Bale an American
Psycho in an odd turn of events
Christian Bale ended up replacing
himself for the role of Patrick baitman
in the 2000 black comedy horror film
American Psycho well sort of director
Mary Heron had chosen Bale for the role
but the British actor wasn't yet the
Superstar he is today Executives at
Lionsgate wanted a higher profile Act
ctor and reportedly made a $20 million
offer to Leonardo DiCaprio without
informing Heron Heron fought hard to
keep bail but Lion's gate eventually
removed her from the project 2 replacing
her with Oliver Stone Stone began
revising the script and the film fell
into a period of Developmental hell
eventually DiCaprio left to film the
beach and stone walked out as well when
Lion's gate finally came back to Heron
she agreed to return as director with
bale as baitman their perseverance
definitely paid off as the film became a
polarizing box office success an
eventual cult classic helping Propel
Bale to the top of Hollywood's A-list
wow isn't this a coincidence Hugh
Jackman in X-Men although he ended up
Landing the role of Wolverine in X-Men
Hugh Jackman wasn't director Brian
singer's First Choice originally singer
wanted Russell Crow who turned it down
Crow recommended his friend Jackman for
the part but singer decided to go with
the more experienced actor D gray Scott
unfortunately for Scott production on
Mission Impossible 2 was delayed leaving
him unavailable when filming for X-Men
began forced to make a last minute
change in the main cast singer called in
Jackman for an audition gave him the
role and the rest is history Gina Davis
in A League of Their Own with her
performance as Daddy Hinson in the 1992
Sports dramedy A League of Their Own
Gina Davis won the hearts of movie goers
everywhere hey who's the manager I am
act like it you big Lush however
director Penny Marshall's original
choice was actress Deborah Winger who
was Furious when she learned that
Marshall had cast pop super Star Madonna
in the film Marshall later recalled in
her Memoir that before walking off the
set Winger told her you're making an
Elvis film subsequently Davis nailed her
audition in Marshall's backyard and
proved that she could throw a ball while
the rest of the cast have been training
together for months prior to filming
Davis had to work hard and fast to get
into shape for the demanding role
Michael bean and Aliens It's probably
hard to picture anyone but Michael Bean
as Dwayne Hicks in the 1986 movie Aliens
but originally it was supposed to be
James Remar however a couple of weeks
after filming started Remar abruptly
left the production he later revealed
during a sidebar podcast interview that
while he had originally cited urgent
matters at home to explain his departure
the truth is that he was struggling with
drug addiction at the time and director
James Cameron fired Remar after he was
arrested for possession with no time to
prepare for the physically demanding
role Michael Bean was brought in as
remar's replacement Ed Harris in The
Truman Show the critically acclaimed
satirical film The Truman Show wouldn't
be the same without the character
Kristoff the obsessive showrunner played
masterfully by Ed Harris but director
Peter Weir didn't choose Harris at first
originally Dennis Hopper was cast in the
role after filming began Weir and Hopper
reportedly ran into creative differences
on the set leading Hopper to leave the
production entirely Hopper later
revealed that he was fired after only 2
days of filming a decision he called a
major blow at the time called up at the
last minute to replace Hopper Harris
threw himself into the role earning
himself an Oscar nomination and a Golden
Globe win for best supporting actor
Clint East wood and Dirty Harry in
addition to his performance as the man
with no name Clint Eastwood is also
frequently remembered for his portrayal
of the hardest Nails homicide cop Harry
Callahan and Dirty Harry but the role
almost went to another famous performer
Frank Sinatra supposedly the script
written for Sinatra had Harry toing a 12
gauge shotgun as his signature weapon
but as production got underway Sinatra
had to back out a broken hand he
sustained while filming a fight scene
for The Manchurian Candidate left him
unable to hold a gun after ensuring the
original script would be used Eastwood
agreed to play Harry cementing his place
in pop culture history with a 44 magnum
and the frequently misquoted line you've
got to ask yourself one question do I
feel
lucky well do you
punk having the right actor or actress
is an ingal aspect of any successful TV
show sometimes these stars are so
important that the show can't go on
without them here are some major TV
shows that just couldn't recover from
the loss and replace M of a leading
actor Sleepy Hollow Fox's Supernatural
police drama was always a little bit
different than other cop shows for
starters one of its main characters was
ikabod crane from Washington Irving's
short story The Legend of Sleepy Hollow
who comes back to life in the present
day after having died 200 years or so
prior cran then helps fight Supernatural
menaces alongside police Lieutenant Abby
mels over three seasons Sleepy Hollow
settled into its role as a quirky police
procedural and then it did the
unthinkable Abby died and actress Co
beeri left the series despite a steep
loss of viewers from season 1 to season
3 Sleepy Hollow returned for a fourth
season without Abby EAB was now
partnered with a Homeland Security agent
named Diana Thomas the cast reboots
didn't do Sleepy Hollow any favors
though the show fell even further in the
ratings and was soon cancelled after
seven seasons of the hitf fox sitcom
actor TOA Grace decided to leave that 70
show in order to more fiercely pursue
his blossoming film career Eric wasn't
the only member of the gang who left
Kelo played by the show's other biggest
star Ashton Kutcher also left the show
although Kutcher stuck around for a few
episodes in season 8 to explain his
character's departure to replace two
very big holes in its cast producers
hired just one actor Mad TV veteran Josh
Meyers his character Randy gets a job at
Hyde's record store and has a brief
relationship with Donner Eric's old
girlfriend neither Randy nor Myers have
much time to M to The Ensemble the
decimated cast may have contributed to
the show's diminish popularity and
inevitable ending the the eighth season
of That 70 show would be its last
although Grace and Kutcher would both
come back to say goodbye for the finale
it's like we never run out of things to
talk about down there I knew you burnout
would be down here you guys it's almost
midnight Mrs Foreman is pouring the
champagne step by step was an ABC sitcom
about Carol and Frank Lambert two single
parents who bring their families
together in addition to all their kids
Frank's nephew Cody lived in a van
outside the house Cody was a
good-natured airheaded California dude
basically a sitcom version of Ted from
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure and
I'm Ted Theodore Logan yeah affable and
enthusiastic acting by Sasha Mitchell
made the character a fan favorite but in
1995 when Mitchell was arrested for
spousal assault he was convicted later
that year and sentenced to 3 years of
Probation and spousal abuse counseling
Mitchell wound up behind bars for
violating his parole and reportedly
attacked his wife again at the beginning
of the six season of step- by- Step Cody
was gone replaced by Jean Luke a heavily
accented hairdresser colleague of carols
playing John Luke was Bronson pincho
best known for playing the excitable
heavily accented bulky on perfect
strangers and the excitable heavily
accented surge in Beverly Hills cup the
new cast Edition didn't work and ABC
cancelled step by step at the end of the
season the show then moved to CBS for a
final year without pinjo after the first
season of The Facts of Life the number
of main characters was cut from 10 to
just five eastand boarding school hous
mother Mrs Garretts and four female
students after those four graduated in
the fourth season season Mrs Garrett
opened a gourmet shop and hired her
former students and after season 7 Mrs
Garrett herself Charlotte Ray left the
show she thought it was time to move on
later telling Entertainment Weekly that
the show could continue on without her
but producers love the show's Dynamic of
a wise older woman doing out advice to
young women so they created the role of
Mrs Garrett's sister Beverly Anne
however the replacement didn't quite
work and by the nth season The Facts of
Life was unceremoniously cancelled
American Idol has created a number of
stars such as Kelly Clarkson Jennifer
Hudson Adam Lambert and of course Simon
Cal audiences couldn't get enough of the
judge who was often brutally and
hilariously honest with contestants
okay best singer in America oh yeah
right I can honestly say you are the
worst singer in America Cowell was the
biggest star of the series which was the
most watched show on TV for an impress
ented eight straight Seasons but in 2010
after nine Seasons he moved on in part
to develop the American version of his
British talent series series the xfactor
idol producers had a hard time replacing
Cowell as well as fellow original judge
Paula Abdul the Idol judges tables
through a lot of stars take a stab at it
but actual singers just couldn't fill
the void left by the music industry guy
who criticized the singers by the time
Fox pulled the plug on American Idol in
2016 it has slipped out of the top 20
most viewed shows maybe we've made a
mistake I think we may have we've made a
big
M news radio NBC's critically acclaimed
but low watched comedy had no plans to
replace one of It characters and the
best known star but tragedy forced The
Producers hand between the show's fourth
and fifth season star Phil Hartman was
shot to death by his troubled wife it
was a horrific crime and a devastating
loss for the show but in order to
complete enough episodes to sell the
show into syndication news radio was
picked up for another season anyway in
the season premiere it was explained
that Hartman's character pompous radio
newsreader Bill mcneel died of a sudden
heart attack replacing him at the
Newsreaders desk was a new character Max
Lewis weird insecure and wholly
unqualified for the position Max was
portrayed by Hartman's friend and
Saturday Night Live co-star John Lovitz
while litz is a great comic actor he
just couldn't overcome the sadness
looming over news radio love its's first
season would be the show's last for the
Fox television adaptation of Lethal
Weapon CLA Crawford took over for Mel
Gibson as Loose Cannon Martin Rigs and
if onset reports published by variety at
any indication Crawford was even harder
to control than his character in an
episode he directed a special effects
explosion went to R sending a piece of
debris at co-star Damon wein when wein
complained Crawford referred to his
co-star as a crybaby another time he
reportedly screamed and swore at a group
of children who wandered near on yet
another occasion he reportedly proved so
hard to work with that a director walked
off the set in the middle of a shoot in
May 2018 after two seasons producers
eliminated what they thought was the
root cause of the show's problems and
fired Crawford they rushed to find
somebody to replace him and quickly
hired Shawn Williams Scots to play
Wesley Cole a new partner for detective
Roger MTAR Scott couldn't save the show
however all that tension didn't totally
dissipate with Wayan's announcing that
he planned to leave the series in the
middle of the Season Fox decided to wash
their hands of the whole thing in May
2019 and canceled Lethal Weapon from
1998 to 2017 Kevin James and Leah reminy
starred on the popular CBS sitcom King
of Queens James would go under star in a
string of movies like grown-ups and Pa
blot mop but in 2016 he returned to the
weekly CBS sitcom grind with Kevin
Conway James portrayed Kevin Gable a
family man who has to delay retiring
from his police job due to family and
money issues playing opposite James was
Aaron Hayes as Kevin's wife Donna Gable
at least that's how it was for the first
season Kevin can weight producers revamp
the show for season two they killed off
Donna Gable and fired hay James
explained the decision to the New York
daily news by saying we were literally
just running out of ideas they also
brought in a new face who was really a
familiar face surprisingly Leah reminy
joined Kevin conit as Kevin's business
partner Vanessa however the nostalgic
rebooting couldn't overcome the weird
behind the scenes shakeup and ratings
actually dropped in season 2 after the
conclusion of the sitcom's second ill-
fated season CBS didn't wait to cancel
Kevin an ensemble drama with a
culturally diverse cast set in an often
surreal rural Alaska Northern Exposure
was radically different from most other
shows on television Rob Marrow starred
as Dr Joel fman a snobby New York City
Doctor Who heads North to service the
Tiny Town of Sicily Northern Exposure
was a big hit reaching the top 20 in the
ratings and earning four straight Emy
nominations for Outstanding Drama Series
and winning the prize in 1992 but
flashman's desire to leave Alaska never
faded and Marrow wanted to bounce too
halfway through the show's sixth season
Maro fled Northern Exposure reportedly
to pursue new acting challenges and a
movie career replacing him was a new
Precision Dr Philip Capra portrayed by
Paul provenza a respected standup
comedian who had little acting
experience apart from his work on
sitcoms that an experience seems to have
showed after just half a season with
provenza at the helm the network
cancelled Northern Exposure the high
school sitcom Head of the Class debuted
on ABC in 1986 it explored the
relationships between a diverse group of
Highly Advanced Manhattan students and
the history teacher Charlie Moore played
by Howard hesman a big part of why Head
of the Class worked is that it was
Ensemble focused the various kids had
personal and academic problems and Mr
Moore helped them sort things out hesman
portrayed more with understatement and
subtlety letting his younger co-stars
take Center Stage however the actor
hated Head of the Class in 1989 he told
a reporter that he thought the show
didn't have much worth He said we're not
doing the show that I was led to believe
I'd do and it's difficult for me to get
off that unsurprisingly hesman left the
show in 1990 in his place was Scottish
comedian Billy Connelly as a teacher
named Billy McGregor all of a sudden a
show about high school kids problems was
a show about wacky Mr McGregor ABC
seemed to realize that too in 1991 the
network cancelled Head of the Class and
quickly ordered up a new show called
Billy Connelly continued to play
McGregor who was now living as a border
in a California Single mother's house
Community never had a huge audience
during its 5-year run on NBC
nevertheless NBC kept renewing the
critically acclaimed comedy about the
disperate people who compromised a
Colorado Community College study group
that loyalty remained even after
increasing difficulties with Community
Creator and showrunner Dan Haron who was
fired and then rehired however five
seasons was ultimately NBC's limit
leaving internet giant Yahoo to step in
and read new community for a sixth
season Show's going to last 3 weeks six
seasons in a movie original regulars Joe
male Jillian Jacobs Danny py Ken Jung
and Allison Bri followed the series to
Yahoo but the show had been losing cast
members and kept losing them as it
transitioned to streaming Chevy Chase
Donald Glover and deette Nicole Brown
were not part of the regular cast of
Community sixth season new actors were
added but the Band-Aid casting just
didn't work and there was no seventh
season of Community not enough people
tuned in and the show didn't generate as
much advertising Revenue as Yahoo had
hoped in fact the revenue was so small
that it effectively led to the complete
shutdown of Yahoo's screen Yahoo CFO Ken
Goldman said on an earnings call that
the company lost $42 million because of
community and its two other original
series scrubs a dram about medical
interns desperately trying to figure out
what they were doing as they worked in a
hospital was a critically acclaimed Emy
nominated hit over its first few seasons
on NBC the network finally dropped
scrubs after seven seasons in 2008 but
got picked up by ABC to finish things
off with an eth season the show's
writers and cast prepared a true series
finale to cap off those episodes only
for ABC to unexpectedly renew the series
for season 9 by that point however star
Zack bra was ready to move on to other
things so the show was retured and
rebooted no longer taking place at a
teaching hospital but at a medical
school familiar doctors were now
teachers instead of active surgeons bra
moved to the background and the new
narrator and center of the show became
Dr Lucy Bennett ultimately the big
changes were too much to take and the
ninth season of Scrubs was its
last casting is a key ingredient in the
secret sauce of great film making in the
best cases a certain performer filling a
certain character's shoes can turn apart
into a franchise leading phenomenon but
the real magic is in Synergy when
several actors click there's no X Files
without David ovy and Jillian Anderson
and what would the original Star Wars
movies have been without Mark Hamill
Carrie Fischer and Har and Ford together
but sometimes an actor's got to go it's
awful for the wouldbe star who watches
the role end up becoming part of a
massive hit while their replacement
reaps the rewards and it's just as bad
for the actors who willfully walk away
from the role of a lifetime never to be
heard from again the almost king of
Gondor the Lord of the Rings is a
sprawling epic with no single lead
character the entire point of the film
Trilogy is that it takes the combined
strength and skill of many to overcome
the dark lord Sauron that said there's
one character that stands out as the
film's Mightiest Hero a great Warrior
who also just so happens to be the heir
to the most powerful Kingdom in Middle
Earth Aragorn son of arthorn it's the
type of role that can turn an unknown
into a worldwide Superstar and it did
just that for vgo Mortenson which is all
too bad for steuart Townsen who will
always be remembered as the man who
almost played Aragorn if he's Remembered
at all Townsen was director Peter
Jackson's original choice to play the
man who would be king of Gondor but he
was let go only a few days into filming
according to Jackson Townsen was simply
too young to be playing the veteran
Warrior to this day Mort is synonymous
with the character as for poor Townsen
he's gotten Parts here and there but
otherwise he's just another casualty of
the war of the Rings The Dragon's other
mother it's become one of the biggest
and most influential series on
television but Game of Thrones wasn't
always a sure thing to try to bring the
books to screen HBO ordered a pilot
episode before the rest of the series
was shot and it was a disaster
fortunately HBO chose to stick with the
project old scenes were cut new scenes
were written the director was replaced
and several cast members were swapped
out of the latter none were more
significant than the recasting of
Daenerys Targaryen one of the most
important characters in the entire story
Tams and Merchant played the role in the
pilot for undisclosed reasons however
Amelia Clark was brought on board to
take her place Game of Thrones has gone
on to become HBO's most successful
series and Clark has taken on starring
roles in everything from romantic
comedies to Star Wars even as she
continues to portray the Mother of
Dragons Merchant meanwhile has continued
to work steadily but is still waiting
for her big breakout role I am daen
Stormborn of House
Taren messing with the timeline Back to
the Future was always a zany concept a
time traveling DeLorean unites an 80s
teen with his teenage parents in the
1950s and shenanigans and Su it went on
to become a defining movie of the decade
and turned lead actor Michael J fox into
a superstar but Fox almost wasn't in the
timeline at all since he wasn't the
original Marty McFly in fact Eric stultz
had already shot weeks worth of footage
in the role before being Let Go by the
director Fox rocketed the household name
stat St while stal settled into steady
work on TV and in indie films he did get
a Golden Globe nomination in 1985 for
mask but for all that Talent he never
had the star power of a time-traveling
DeLorean true of us all I can't guess
you guys aren't ready for that yet
mission impossible for this mutant X-Men
launched the Modern Wave of superhero
movies when it was released in 2000 and
while there are quite a few of the
titular Heroes represented in that first
movie none was more popular and more
enduring than Wolverine the cigar
chomping Canadian has always been a
comic book favorite so it was absolutely
essential that the character be cast
with the right actor that's why the
filmmakers went with du gry Scott the
Scottish actor was an unknown at the
time but since the whole X-Men film was
being cast with relative newcomers he
seemed like a great choice to bring the
gruff living weapon with the adamantium
skeleton to life the only problem was
the film that got him attention in the
first place mission impossible to the
film reportedly ran over schedule
forcing Scott to stay behind on that
project Hugh Jackman was cast instead
the start of what would be a long and
successful career in and out of
superhero movies Scott mean meanwhile
has never achieved the same level of
Fame what a couple of claws might have
done for him we'll never know you know
so part of my past it never really you
know I never think about it to be honest
with you Blown Away by Arnold when James
Cameron set out to write and direct the
first Terminator film he was a nobody
his biggest directorial effort up to
that time was Piranha 2 a movie he was
fired from which featured actor Lance
henriksson Cameron liked henriksson and
envisioned him as the titular cyborg for
Terminator but then Along Came an
Austrian bodybuilder named Arnold
Schwarz AER who' just come off playing
the lead character in Conan the
Barbarian with his sheer physical
presence he was the obvious choice to
play the Terminator in every way the
Terminator was Schwarzenegger's movie
and it vaulted him into the upper
echelon of the Decades action Stars
henriksson meanwhile has stayed busy
over the years albeit in the types of
character actor roles that don't spawn
catchphrases or multi-million dollar
sequels I'll be back a Tarantino twist
and casting Quinton Tarantino is one of
the most meticulous Craftsmen in the
business he writes his own Scripts and
he knows exactly how he wants to shoot
them Tarantino knows that a scene must
be tuned with perfect precision and that
includes perfect casting Michael Madson
turned in a memorable performance as Mr
blonde in Tarantino's film Reservoir
Dogs so when he began filling out the
roster for his follow-up feature Pulp
Fiction Tarantino wanted Madson back
Madson was forced to turn down the role
in favor of a part in Kevin Cosner's
Western Wyatt herb it probably made
sense at the time Cosner was an
established star whereas Tarantino was
still an indie filmmaker in madson's
place John travolto was cast as Vincent
Vega it was exactly what Travolta needed
he earned an Oscar nomination and a
second win for his career Wyatt her
meanwhile went nowhere Madson has an
impressive slew of credits to his name
but has never attracted the type of fame
or Acclaim Travolta enjoyed post pulp
transforming lead actress Megan Fox was
still largely unknown when she was cast
in the lead female role in Michael Bay's
2007 film Transformers the film was a
huge box office hit and fox became a
worldwide star her return in the 2009
sequel transform Mer's Revenge of the
Fallen cemented her status as one of
Blockbuster Cinema's hottest new stars
there was nowhere for her to go but up
until it all came crashing down Fox was
unceremoniously fired from the third
film Transformers Dark of the Moon
initially intended to return she was
thrown out for being too difficult to
work with and for her criticism of ba
while the new lead actress technically
took on a brand new character this was
still the girlfriend of shy La Buff's
hero effectively the same role Fox's
career has never been quite the same
since her most high-profile outings have
been in the rebooted teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles series and the ill- fated
Jonah Hex otherwise she hasn't seen many
starring roles in films Blockbusters or
otherwise sometimes it isn't just being
replaced that damages your career it's
the reasons why you know I tell it like
it is that's a negative Ghost Rider
Matthew modine's movie career was just
heating up in the early 1980s he seemed
like a great candidate to star in a New
Patriotic action film titled Top Gun but
Modine chose to walk away from the offer
since he was uncomfortable with what he
felt was an unabashedly pro-military F
film instead the job went to Tom Cruz
who used his performance as Maverick to
help launch one of the most successful
movie careers in history Cruz became one
of the industry's biggest stars and Top
Gun was the Turning Point the movie that
changed his life forever Modine hasn't
had the same luck he's carved out an
impressive career in his own right
turning in acclaimed performances and a
long list of projects that includes full
metal jacket and the hit Netflix series
stranger things but he's kept a much
lower profile than he might have if he'd
taken that fateful role he refused top
gun out of principal but it didn't come
without cost what a very Maverick thing
to
do cast can get disrupted for a variety
of reasons sometimes schedules change
sometimes personal problems can lead an
actor to drop out in some cases things
still turn out well or even better for
the films in question but in others it
damages the cast chemistry and Dooms the
film one of the most famous recastings
of all time was that of Eric staltz and
Back to the Future stultz was the
original Marty McFly a time-traveling
teenager who's accidentally sent back to
the year 1955
he was replaced with Michael J fox a
little over a month into shooting Leah
Thompson who played Marty's Mom Lorraine
told The Hollywood Reporter in 2015 that
the switch was very difficult for her as
she was very good friends with stultz
fellow castmate Christopher Lloyd who
starred as inventor Doc Brown gave a
radio interview in 2012 and described
the moment the cast found out stolz was
history it was during an intense period
of night shooting after he'd been
working with staltz every night for 3
weeks he noted that staltz was a very
good actor but The Producers needed
someone with more of a comic flare in
the role Lloyd was terrified when he
reshot his scenes with Fox but he was
happy that it all worked out in the end
Great Scott did it ever this young adult
romance between high school student
Bella Swan and vampire Edward Cullen
captivated readers and movie goers
around the globe in the first two
twilight films the vampire Victoria was
played by relle leev but in the third
entury Eclipse Victoria didn't seem like
her old self as leev had been replaced
by Bryce Dallas Howard Summit
entertainment and leev had an awkwardly
public battle over the move with the
actress saying she was stunned and the
studio countering that they were
disappointed by her attempt to make her
career choices the fault of the studio
whether the fault lay with Lev's
scheduling or summit's ruthlessness the
switch was hard on her castmates Jackson
wrath bone who played Cullen coven
member Jasper hail noted that leev was a
dear friend whom he was going to miss
terribly and Peter fanelli who starred
as Edward's adoptive father declared
that he loved her like a sister Ang Lee
picked up a Best Director Oscar for life
of pie his adaptation of yan Martell's
novel in which a man retells the story
of his week surviving in a shipwreck at
the age of 16 a drift on the Pacific
Ocean with only a bangal tiger in his
Lifeboat for company his story is told
to a writer who was played in the film
by RAF spal but originally that part was
filled by Toby Maguire Lee ended up
removing Maguire after shooting wrapped
because he felt his presence took away
from the story he insisted that he loved
Toby whom he had worked with previous
viously in 1997's the ice storm but he
worried that it would be distracting to
have a big movie star sitting there for
such a small part uron Khan who played
the adult Pi was Jarred by the recasting
as it meant he had to re-shoot those
scenes he was worried about having to
make a big emotional investment all over
again but it ended up working out as he
learned from his director to use the
opportunity constructively there was a
lot of pressure to deliver satisfying
sequels to The Matrix the groundbreaking
1999 sci-fi cyberpunk classic that
pressure only increased when numerous
production issues LED observers to
wonder if the series was cursed this
included numerous deaths of cast members
including Gloria Foster who played the
Oracle and who passed away just after
the filming of the Matrix Reloaded and
there was also the tragic case of aiyah
who was initially cast as Z and reloaded
the singer and actress was killed in a
plane crash at the age of 22 in the
midst of production co-star Harold panu
remembered her fondly it was a really
hard loss personally it was a really
hard loss for you the community of music
and entertainment and and uh and we'll
miss her the re audition process for Z
took many months eventually Nona gay
daughter of singer Marvin Gay was cast
as her replacement the drama on the set
of 1996's the island of Dr Moro is
legendary it may have started when Bruce
Willis had to drop out of the lead role
and director Richard Stanley was
reportedly told the only way to save the
film was to hire Val Kilmer who
ultimately realized his leverage and
allegedly started making demands Stanley
was eventually replaced by John
frankenheimer but that didn't stop
Kilmer from causing disruptions
according to crew members he would
arrive late change dialogue and Bully
the cas and crew one witness reported
that he even intentionally burned a
cameraman right on his face with a
cigarette Kilmer's Behavior also led him
to a feud with co-star Marlon Brando
Kilmer repeatedly refused to emerge from
his trailer until Brando was on set and
Brando would only come on to the set
after a private discussion with
frankenheimer according to the director
this led to days going by without any
footage being shot as extras sat around
in their makeup in full costumes in the
heat when Charlie hunam and Dakota
Johnson were announced as the stars of
50 Shades of Gray it looked like they
had the chemistry necessary for the
bondage lace tail yet that chemistry
wasn't enough to keep hunam on board
four weeks before shooting was set to
commence he dropped out citing
scheduling conflicts Johnson later
explained during an interview with David
Letterman that it was a confusing moment
for her Ham's replacement Jamie Dornan
seemed to mulfy some fan objection but
by all accounts lack the chemistry
Johnson had with hunam for one thing
their press tour was low energy they're
that instant
chemistry no you hate each
other he's hard to work
with and while the film was a hit the
pair didn't generate enough Sparks to
win over most
critics more than a decade before
universals attempted Dark Universe and
its Tom Cruz L mummy reboot their
original efforts at bringing the classic
monster back to the big screen were
certified hits the Mummy Trilogy which
kicked off in 1999 and concluded with
2008's critically panned The Mummy Tomb
of the Dragon Emperor killed it at the
box office raking in a collective $1.25
billion worldwide a major reason for the
success of the first two mummy films was
the solid cast which helped Revitalize
the action adventure genre by infusing
it with both horror and comedy they took
what could have been a set of camp
period films and made them appeal to a
younger audience through witty dialogue
and thrilling action most generally
touted Brendan Fraser as Rick oconnell
as the centerpiece of the Mummy Universe
But Rising Star Rachel vice's work as
Evelyn Eevee oconnell proved just as
intrical vice's performance in the mummy
turned out to be her big break she
signed on to do The Mummy Returns
without question but she's mysteriously
absent from Tomb of the Dragon Emperor
in which Maria Bellow played Eevee
instead the reason for vice's departure
from the project was actually laid to
rest nearly 12 years ago but hasn't
necessarily become common knowledge when
talks of a third film in the mummy
continuity began to pick up steam back
in 2007 so did discussions about why
Rachel Vice wasn't attached to the
project one common rumor ran rampant
about her distaste for the script which
she reportedly felt went against E's
character another was started by
director Rob Cohen who believed it had
something to do with Rick and Eve's
27-year-old son Alex whose inclusion
would require Vice to be aged up for the
third movie Vice put the whole debacle
to bed during an interview back in 2008
when she explained that she never got
the chance to even look at the script
she had also just finished on Ryan
Johnson's the Brothers Bloom and was
about to begin work on another film
immediately so she wouldn't have a
moment to spare couple that with her and
Darren aronovsky newborn son waiting for
her at home there was no time for a trip
to China for 5 months Tomb of the Dragon
Emperor was a critical flop and prompted
Universal to rethink their plans for a
follow-up based around the AXS little
did Vice know back then that she
couldn't have pulled out of the series
at a better
time hey
Mom sorry I blamed you guys for raising
the
emperor to say the mummy Tomb of the
Dragon Emperor suffered without Vice
would be an
understatement the film is the lowest
rated of the trilogy with an abysmal 12%
critic score on Rotten Tomatoes movie
goers didn't find it Charming either as
its audience score was only slightly
better at 30% in the audience comments
on the aggregator site many franchise
fans noted that the film took a hit with
vice's absence one viewer wrote
ultimately the absence of Rachel Vice
and the change in location and mythology
are the biggest flaws in this film Vice
was a major part of the first two films
and by having her replaced by Maria
Bellow the original character is lost
and replaced with one that doesn't meet
vice's performance swapping out actors
at the end of a Trilogy is a huge risk
we wonder if it might have been better
to leave out Eevee entirely to not
frustrate and confuse the franchise's
fans while Vice wasn't in the film there
was a nice homage to her is the
scarletto Keef character really based on
you honestly I can say she's a
completely different person Bellow
praised a moment in an interview with
kollider saying it was a great comment
on it I lik the idea that I wrote novels
and the woman I wrote was this amazing
beautiful Rachel Vice anenu and she was
the character because she's so perfect
and then there's me in my Mansion bored
to death following the release of Tomb
of the Dragon Emperor Bella was on board
for another mummy film but Universal
canel project in 2012 the Tom Cruz mummy
reboot in 2017 flopped hard killing the
planned Dark Universe so who knows
what's in store for the franchise it
just might come back to
life not every Harry Potter star made it
through all eight movies a few of them
were switched out for a wide range of
reasons including death run-ins with the
law and embarrassing scandals here are
some of the major Harry Potter
characters who were ultimately recast
between films and the stories of how
those transfigurations came to be
although there's still plenty of Potter
fans who prefer Richard Harris's
depiction of Dumbledore the role was
nonetheless recast ahead of Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of aaban after the
two-time Oscar winner passed away in
2002 from Hodgkins disease Harris had
expected that he might not be able to
carry on in the role forever which he
first took to please his granddaughter
he told the press that I'll keep doing
it as long as I enjoy it my health holds
out and they still want me but the
chances of all three of those factors
remaining constant are pretty slim the
part would eventually go to Michael
gambin Who start in all six following
films but gambin wasn't the only British
star invited to Dawn the heaping wig and
decadent cloaks years after the fact sir
Ian McKellen revealed that he too had a
shot at becoming alus Dumbledore but
turned it down I I couldn't I I I
couldn't take over the part from an
actor who I'd known didn't approve of me
Harris had reportedly been unim trust
with McKellen's career implying that he
was a passionless actor despite all this
McKellen added that he sometimes saw
himself on posters which featured gambin
as Dumbledore when Lord Voldemort first
appeared on screen in Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer Stone there wasn't a lot
for the actor portraying him to do after
all he was mostly hidden behind
Professor Coral's turban throughout the
story and even when he did emerge his
face was superimposed on the back of
coral skull Richard Grimmer did what he
could with the role but wasn't surprised
when he wasn't invited back to reprise
his part in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire brimer told this is Northeast
The Producers spent a long time fighting
to get me so I'm very proud to have been
the first but the role is now being
played by R Vines who's an old mate in
the fourth film I've been in the
business a long time and it didn't
surprise me that they went for a bigger
name being Hollywood Le and I'm happy to
pass it on to Rafe findes was already an
a-lister by the time sorcerer Stone was
released having one Oscar nominations
for Schindler's List and The English
Patient so it's no surprise that the
filmmakers didn't seek him out for that
brief CGI appearance Jamie whet did an
apt enough job as Draco Malfoy's pastry
loving henchman Vincent crab like many
of his contemporaries in the series the
young actor was completely new to the
world of film when he suited up as the
Slytherin scant but was gradually given
more and more screen time throughout his
Six film tenure by the time Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hollows arrived however
crab's other half Gregory Goyle was seen
standing next to a new Malfoy Lieutenant
Blaze zabini crab was completely out of
the picture and while the role itself
wasn't cast the character was shuffled
out of sight to make room for zabini
this all stemmed from wet's off camera
runin with the law whet was arrested in
2009 after he was caught growing
marijuana plants in his mother's home
that incident alone was enough to lose
him his prime position in the Potter
world and the troubles would only
continue from there the actor was later
arrested again in 2012 for participating
in a riot and this time he faced jail wh
let's coastar Jesse cave would later
publicly rise to his defense but the
damage was still done and the actor
hasn't worked on a film since when the
Gryffindor common room portrait known as
the fat lady first appeared in Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer Stone it was
celebrated actress Elizabeth sprigs who
portrayed her however sprigg's portrayal
was brief and rather rigid in blly
asking for the prefect's password so
before the character would return in
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of aaban
the actress was replaced with Dawn
French French brought a more comedic
element to the character as she
desperately tries to impress the Hogwart
student body with her glass breaking
operatic
skills
[Applause]
amazing J my voice French earned the
role after her Harry Potter spoof for
charity caught the attention of director
and producer Christopher Columbus
Columbus told the BBC I think she's
incredibly funny and her Harry Potter
spoof for comic relief was pretty
amazing the casting of the Harry Potter
films was entirely limited to British
thespians a rule so strict it even
forced producers to turn down Robin
Williams for the role of Hagrid but Vern
Troyer became the rare exception when he
was cast as gring got's Banker grip hook
in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer Stone
Troyer was the only American actor with
a major role in the film but the
character was voiced by his English
co-star War Davis who also portrayed
Professor Flitwick and another bank
teller in the film but by the time grip
hook became more significant to the
story in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hollows Davis had taken over the role
completely grip has so much more depth
to him that I ever been able to get into
work as Professor Flitwick and so I went
in and read for David Yates though it
was never reported as the reason for
troyer's replacement the actor had been
caught up in a number of embarrassing
scandals following the first film's
release sometimes the actors who play
the bad guys we love to hate have to
pass the role to someone else maybe it's
because of behind thes scenes drama or
perhaps it's because of busy schedules
here are the real reasons these super
villain actors were replaced
Frank Goran played the quizzing villain
The Riddler in the 60s Batman series
riddle me this Prime fighter what room
can no one enter goran's masked
trickster remained one of the most
well-loved villains of the series and
even Mark Hamill named him as one of his
influences for his work on the Joker his
Riddler is like one of my favorite comic
book villains of all time I love frank
Goran yet in Batman's second season
Goran inexplicably disappeared for two
episodes and was replaced by John Aston
who's best known as Gomez Adams from The
Adams Family they were aston's only
appearances as the brain teasing bad guy
and caution eventually returned to the
role there are different stories about
why the brief hiccup in casting happened
gon's version was that he had a
nightclub appearance commitment he
couldn't get out of that conflicted with
the shooting schedule but Batman
producer William dosier claimed that
Goran talent agency demanded more money
for the actor's appearances on the show
than its budget could bear two of
Marvel's most vicious Rivals are
Wolverine and Victor Creed AKA
Sabertooth fans got a tiny piece of that
rivalry on the big screen in 2000's
X-Men when retired professional wrestler
Tyler M played saber-tooth as part of
Magneto's Brotherhood he doesn't say
much but he gets a couple of good
throwdowns with Hugh Jackman's Logan but
when it was time to give Logan his first
solo flick with 2009's X-Men Origins
Wolverine Maine was nowhere to be seen
instead it was leev shriber playing The
Savage mutant speaking to The Hollywood
Reporter in 2017 Maine said he didn't
get to play sabertooth in the prequel
because the filmmakers wanted someone
who looked more like Jackman the
wrestler explained the storyline was
them Rising as brothers and leev and Q
look a lot closer in that respect so I
understand I can't say I wasn't
disappointed I'd love to get my claws
back into that role but that's
Hollywood Hugo weaving played the
villainous Red Skull in 2011's Captain
America the First Avenger but when the
character surprised audiences 7 years
later by showing up in Avengers Infinity
War there was another actor under all
the Prosthetics in order to take the
stone you must lose that which you love
while the accent and The Voice May have
sounded right it was actually a skilled
impression by Walking Dead actor Ross
Marquand not weaving weaving's decision
to sit this one out was hardly
surprising since the actor told kollider
in 2012 that he had no intention of
reprising the Marvel role while
acknowledging that he' signed a
multi-picture contract with Marvel he
said he didn't think Marvel would try to
force the matter if he said no but it
turns out that weaving may have been
willing to return if Marvel had honored
the terms of his contract he told time
out in 2020 that Marvel had tried to
negotiate a lower rate for Infinity war
and its sequel Avenger end game then was
promised in his original contract as a
result weaving bowed out opening the
door for Mark wand the first actress to
play Batman's feline antagonist Catwoman
in the 60s TV series was Julie numar who
actually returned to the role in two
recent animated features 2016's Batman
Return of the Caped Crusaders and the
following years's Batman versus Twoface
unfortunately when it came time to film
the 1966 Batman movie with the cast of
the TV show numar was shooting the soon
Tobe abandoned comedy missure L cook she
was replaced for the film by Lee
Merryweather although numar continued
playing the character on the show the
Batman's third and final season Yar left
the series to make the Weston McKenna's
gold and actress and singer earther kit
took up the role of Gotham's top cat
burglar because kit was African-American
it was deemed too controversial at the
time for her and Batman to keep teasing
each other so their romantic connection
unfortunately
disappeared while he never got any acid
thrown on him fans were guessing that at
Turner's Toof face might EV eventually
be in the cards for Billy D Williams
when he played Harvey Dent in 1989's
Batman in that film Dent had just become
Gotham city's new district attorney and
hadn't yet suffered the catastrophic
injury that would prompt his shift from
Batman Ally to super villain for your
dying pleasure we are serving the very
same as that made us the men we are
today however at the 2017 Wizard World
Nashville ComicCon Williams told fans
that his chance to play Twoface ended
when director Joel schoem marker took
the Reigns from Tim Burton on Batman
Forever Williams explained I had hoped
that I would have done Toof face but it
changed hands before then and I think
scho marker got involved so they took a
different direction with that however
Williams did eventually get to play
Twoface in a different format in 2017 he
voiced the iconic villain in the Lego
Batman movie The Mid credit scene of
2012's The Avengers briefly introduced
movie audiences to Thanos but it wasn't
until Avengers Infinity war that the
villain finally became the focus of the
main story The Thanos we met in the
Avengers mid credit scene isn't the same
guy who plays The Mad Titan in the rest
of the infinity Saga True Blood actor
Damen portier played Thanos at the end
of The Avengers but there was no drama
behind the decision to replace him in
the MCU Avengers director Jos Weeden
admitted he really wasn't sure exactly
what to do with Thanos after the
Avengers implying there was no real
long-term plan when forier was cast by
the time the characters came around
again in 2014's Guardians of the Galaxy
Marvel had a clearer idea of thanos's
trajectory in the MCU and Josh Brolin
was cast in the role as Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige put it Brolin
could be Thanos without any effects he
has that kind of face and that kind of
Gravitas I am
inevitable in 2009 the video game Batman
Arkham Asylum was released and quickly
earned the reputation as one of the best
superhero video games ever one of the
game's highlights was the return of
voice actors from the popular Batman the
Animated Series television show most
notably Kevin Conroy as Batman and Mark
Hamill as the Joker look at all this new
security how's a guy supposed to break
out out of here Conroy and Hamill would
lend their voices to follow-ups like
Arkham City Arkham Knight and Arkham VR
but both were missing from the 2013
prequel game Batman Arkham Origins
instead of Hamill the clown Prince of
Crime was voiced by Troy Baker an
official reason has never been offered
for Hamill's absence from Arkham Origins
but we know a couple of likely
contributing factors first while he
would eventually do Joker's voice again
for other games as well well as the 2016
animated adaptation Batman The Killing
Joke Hamill told IGN in 2012 he had no
intention of ever voicing The Joker
again second unlike the first two Arkham
games which were developed by Rock
Steady Arkham Origins was developed by
WB Montreal which reportedly couldn't
spare as big of a
budget sometimes a TV show can make big
cast shifts and not suffer too many
consequences but other aren't so lucky
these major TV shows just couldn't
recover from the loss and replacement of
a major character or the actor who
played them Dallas had its fair share of
character Replacements during its run
from 1978 to 1991 as any show that airs
for 14 Seasons inevitably does but one
that still stands out with fans to this
day is the role of Miss Ellie Ying
Barbara Bell Gettys originated the part
and played it right up until 1984
when she left in order to have a
quadruple bypass heart surgery at the
time she was replaced by Donna Reed and
fans were not into it in fact fans were
so nod into it that 6 months later when
Bel Gettys had recovered she was asked
back onto the show Reed didn't go down
without a fight though she tried to Sue
and halt production in the end the judge
didn't agree with her and the series
carried on Bell Gettys continued playing
Miss eing for the remainder of the
series bringing life to the character
for over 300 episodes when suits hit
Airwaves in 2011 critics had positive
but somewhat mixed reviews on the
premise which turned the tired legal
drama format on its head with the
introduction of Mike Ross a wanabe
lawyer without a degree and Harvey
Spectre the Hot Shot attorney who
mentored him shot in Toronto the series
wound up being a massive hit for the
network and was considered the last of
its blue skies era hey you ready for
this yeah yeah I am however that all
ended in 2017 when Patrick J Adams and
Megan Markle who played Mike Ross in his
love interest Rachel Zayn respectively
announced they were leaving the show
after seven seasons at that point
another original series star G Torres
also exited leaving the cast down three
members as a result the show brought on
Dule Hill and Katherine hiel while
upping Amanda schul from recurring to
full-time status in season 8 however the
new of characters didn't resonate as
well as the old school ones and the Show
wrapped for good in season 9 it seems
like networks have been trying to
recreate the Soapy Prime Time success of
Desperate Housewives ever since that
show went off the air in 2012 ABC
thought it came close with the 2013
entry Mistresses which failed to earn
critical praise but still snagged a
second season renewal following its
steamy first season summer run fans
continued to bake in the hotness of it
all the following summer but when the
show was renewed for a third season ABC
revealed it was moving production from
Los Angeles to Vancouver that was bad
news for Star Alysa Milano who couldn't
be that far from her family Milano
stepped away as a result and the show
recruited Jennifer Esposito to fill that
void with her kalista Reign's character
that lasted one season and then Esposito
also left the series in order to pursue
other projects surprisingly the show was
renewed for one more season but without
Milano fans just didn't seem that into
it and the series was asked for good
after a very dramatic season 4
finale it's no secret that Julie Benz
did not want to exit Dexter after she
was killed off in the show's fourth
season she admitted to reporters that
she quote balled and said it was the
worst thing to ever happen to her in her
career it seems as though fans felt the
same way while the decision was purely a
creative one the salt in the wound for
passionate viewers came in season 5 when
Julia Styles was cast as Lumin Pierce a
new love interest for Dexter the
character lasted the entire season and
finally exited ahead of season 6 for
many it was a turning point especially
as they watched the show go on to cast
other guest stars like Colin Hanks and
Ivon Strahovski to fill the void then
writers eventually went so far as to
almost pair Dexter up with his adoptive
sister Deb now with the belated Showtime
Revival on the way fans are hoping that
the series finally dos out a much more
satisfying series finale
chemistry is particularly important when
casting a family sitcom so fans were a
little concerned when Julia Butters left
American housewife as the youngest Otto
child ahead of its Fifth Season Premiere
Butters brought a notable charm to the
character of Anna cat Otto so much so
that when Quinton Tarantino saw her on
his screen he cast her as serious young
actress Trudy in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood that gig wound up being a game
changer for the young actor because all
kinds of subsequent offers came came in
and she left the ABC series to pursue
them in turn American housewife snatched
up gelle Eisenberg fresh from her 4
season run on the CBS sitcom Life In
Pieces while Eisenberg is undeniably
talented it's been hard for fans to
adapt to the change following the show's
return in
2020 yeah kids change all the witty meta
jokes in the world won't convince
viewers to keep watching the season 5
finale ended up being a series finale
ABC cancelled American housewife in
2021 it's no secret that the children on
Tim Allen's Last Man Standing changed
pretty drastically over the show's run
Amanda Fuller joined the project in
season 2 as Kristen Baxter replacing
Alexandra crosy who originated the role
then there's the fact that four
different actors have played the part of
Kristen's son Boyd as the character has
aged over the years but it was Molly
ephraim's exit from the series Following
Season 6 that really threw Last Man
Standing fans for a loop as middle child
Mandy Ephraim had her share of meaty
storylines that made her a show fixture
but when ABC cancelled last man standing
in 2017 and fox revived it for a seventh
season run efim didn't go with it she
had signed up for new projects and was
unable to return Molly mcook was cast in
her place and although the series lasted
three seasons on Fox before its
cancellation in 2021 the character was
just never the same now this is a story
all about how the casting on Fresh prins
got turned upside down fans everywhere
are familiar with the behind the-scenes
Strife that went down between Will Smith
and original Aunt Viv actress Janet
Hubert who played the role for three
notable Seasons before refusing to renew
her contract under what she considered
to be a bad deal as a result she exited
the show and she was replaced by Daphne
Maxwell Reed an actor who was originally
considered for the role but refused to
audition because a TV show starring a
young young rapper didn't sound like her
thing there a lot of sick demented
perverts out there greetings
all although the fresh prince of belir
went on for three more seasons with the
new a Viv there was no replacing
Hubert's comedic timing later when Smith
got the game back together for the 2020
reunion he and Hubert sat down for the
first time to finally iron things out
the result was the two Aunt vivs meeting
for the very first time as many fans
wondered what the show could have been
had Hu stayed on after all when the
sixth season of this comedy kicked off
in 1969 viewers were left twitching
harder than Samantha in her magical nose
when Emmy nominee Dick York was suddenly
gone as Darren Stevens in his place was
Dick's sergeant and fan speculation as
to what happened kicked into overdrive
as it turned out York had previously
injured his back pretty badly while
shooting a movie and the pain led him
down a dark path of prescription pills
eventually he realized he had to leave
the show and his career never really
recovered as for sergeant he stayed in
the role until the series finale in
1972 many fans felt the series wasn't
the same though and it's worth noting
that although Sergeant won a most
Irreplaceable replacement TV Land award
in 2006 he was never nominated for an
Emmy Award like his
predecessor have you heard the one about
the two Becky when Rosanne kicked off
its first iteration back in 1988 it was
actor ly Goron who originated the Ro of
Becky the eldest child to Dan and
Rosanne fast forward to season 5 though
and Goron had enrolled in college and as
a result she was only available to film
part-time usually for a phone
conversation the following year
producers wanted Becky back in a more
permanent role so they recast her with
Sarah chalk that was fine but things got
complicated when Goron briefly returned
in season 8 after finishing school the
following year chalk was back in the
roll and the two Becky became a running
thing that frustrated some viewers to
their relief both actors were asked back
for the Rosanne Revival in 2018 but only
Genson returned to play Becky producers
hired chalk to instead play a character
named Andrea who asked Becky to be her
surrogate in a clever wink to the whole
situation for five and a half Seasons
Nashville fans followed Connie Britain's
Superstar character Raina James as she
balanced motherhood singing and
reconnecting with her one true love
Deacon Clayborn but that all came
crashing down when Burton shocked fans
and exited the series in 2017 with a
devastating storyline that left her
family all alone it turned out Britain
was ready for a change but she was
having a hard time of letting go of the
people she worked with so when seemed he
revived Nashville for a fifth season
after ABC axed at the end of its run in
2016 Britain decided it was finally time
to move on after the fictional singer's
death there were plenty of other
characters to root for and the show may
have ultim timately survived but then
the writers introduced Caitlyn double
day as Jesse Kane a new love interest
for Deacon and loyal fans were
definitely not happy the series took a
bit of a dive and season 6 ultimately
wound up being the last throughout its
8season run house had a history of
replacing characters to switch up the
storyline and keep things fresh but
season 7 is when the casting situation
really got out of control that year
Olivia wild took a leave of absence from
her fan favorite gig as 13 to film
Cowboys and Aliens while original actor
Lisa Edelstein announced her departure
as Dr Lisa cuy considering the shakeups
it seemed pretty clear to longtime fans
that the series was nearing its
expiration date to try and inject new
life into the show producers hired odet
annabal and Charlene y to play the
latest fellows alongside Amber tamblin
but the new crew never quite lived up to
the original cast and as season 8 was in
progress Fox announced that it would
also be the show's last
today Beverly Hills 90210 is also known
as TV's most famous sift code but before
the show earned that status its original
cast had to win over Prime Time fans
with its older actors and soapy
storylines entered Jason Priestley and
Shannon dhy as the famous Walsh twins
Brandon and Brenda from the start fans
were into their chemistry with the
show's other original cast members but
behind the scenes it was a different
story reports of onset tension between
DH and the rest of the cast specifically
Jenny G surfaced and in 1994 DH was
asked from the show for good that year
she was replaced by Tiffany th who had
her own fan base from her days as Kelly
unsaved by the Bell but not all fans
were into the new character Valerie
Malone a family friend of the walshes it
was clear Val was meant to replace
Brenda but Saved by the Bell fans
weren't sure how to receive this new
adult version of the actor meanwhile the
character had her moments but she was no
Brenda and the tone of the series
changed with her Casting she stayed on
for most of the rest of the series but
to this day you can ask any 90210 fan
which character they relate to most and
you probably won't find many Valerie
stands out
there an actor might be replaced in a
television series due to schedule
conflicts lackluster chemistry behind
the scenes politics or even death
forgotten or not there's drama behind
the curtain it's New York City in the
early 80s Christine Kagney as a modern
single woman and a former fashion model
raised in a comfortable middle class
home Mary Beth Lacy is a no-nonsense
working mom from the neighborhood
together they are beat styling cops they
Patrol the Mean Streets of Midtown
Manhattan while fighting against
institutional sexism in their own ranks
Kagney and Lacy had a passionate fan
base that twice saved it from
cancellation these your women Macy and
kagy inspector Stars Ty daily and Sharon
Gless dominated the lead actress Emmy
category for the entire six-year run of
the series but Gless wasn't the first
actress cast as Kagney or even the
second the series began with a TV movie
starring daily and mashar Loretta Swit
when Swit was unavailable for the show
mag Foster was cast in rep place but
after six episodes Gless took over the
part in a wide- ranging 2008 interview
series producer Barney Rosen swag
revealed the reason for Foster's
departure was one of compatibility her
performance was too similar to what Daly
was creating as Lacy he explained it
became Lacy and Lacy at the time of the
recasting however Rosen swag gave a much
different rationale when interviewed by
TV Guide that viewers found Foster not
feminine enough and that together she
and Dy read as lesbians an apparently
distasteful situation to viewers in 1982
if you have a problem if no one else can
help and if you can find them maybe you
can hire The A Team so goes the famous
opening narration of The A Team Super
producer stevenh J kennel's 1980s action
series about a quartet to Vietnam Vets
who work as mercenaries in the Los
Angeles underground taking the kinds of
suicide missions that no one else is
bold or crazy enough to accept this the
series star 60s leading man George Bard
is Hannibal Smith the leader of the
group Dwight Schultz is pilot Howen mad
Murdoch Rocky 3 breakout Star Mr T is
all ba baracus ba stands for bad
attitude and Battle Star Galactica star
Dirk Benedict as Master of Disguise
Faceman peek but the first time around
facemen had a different face altogether
in the show's pilot episode peek is
played by loveboat star Tim dunigan the
issue with dunigan appropriately enough
was his face though technically old
enough to have served in Vietnam it was
decided that in an's own words he was
too young and too tall for the role
Benedict who had apparently been canel
and co-creator Frank Lupo's First Choice
was cast and played the part for the
rest of the series The Law and Order
franchise is no stranger to inventive
solutions for temporarily unavailable
cast members Law and Order Special
Victims Unit premiered in 1999 the first
franchise spin-off the series follows
the dedicated detectives of the sex
crimes focused Special Victims Unit and
delves further into the personal lives
of its leads than the original show ever
does this is a especially true for
Marisa harate as detective Olivia Benson
and Christopher Maloney as her volatile
partner Elliot Stabler in 2006 it was
announc that harate was taking a short
leave of absence from the show to
accommodate the final months of her
pregnancy in her place the show brought
in Connie neelon as detective Danny back
partnering her with stabler for a six
episode run in the middle of season 8
her character was clearly meant to be
temporary still some fans weren't
pleased by her presence in a 2020
interview neelen said she still gets
Danny Beck hate mail Tony sho's
defective detective in the comedy series
monk was always socially awkward with a
touch of obsessive compulsive disorder
various flashbacks through the seasons
and a visit from his brother confirmed
that his conditions were always present
within him but the moment that turned
his life upside down to the point that
he had to leave the San Francisco police
department and hire a nurse to assist
him was his wife's death his wife Trudy
was murdered by carbomb Monk begins
after Trudy's death but the mystery
surrounding it is the show's primary
ongoing story reaching from the first
episode all the way to the last in the
first two seasons Trudy played by
stellina rusich is represented by a few
silent flashbacks and photographs on
Mon's mantle starting with season 3's
flashback heavy episode Mr Monk in the
game show however Trudy is played in
flashbacks by malora Harden an actress
probably best known for playing Jan
levenson in the office and I have to
thank you for that other thing
too well marrying me oh
look you're welcome paron would appear a
few more times most notably in the two
parts series finale where her murder is
finally solved oddly as the series went
on the prompts Department used photos of
both rusage and Harden interchangeably
and even sat them next to each other in
Monk's
house generational trauma is at the
heart of David Chase's Landmark series
of Sopranos the HBO mob drama that in
many ways revolutionized television
opening the medium up to a more mature
serialized mode of Storytelling Tony
Soprano is a New Jersey mob boss who was
profoundly depressed and dissatisfied
with his life in ways that he can't
articulate much of his trauma can be
traced back to his mother Livia and
Uncle Junior as well as the ghost of his
father Johnny Boy beginning with season
2 Tony's Wayward Sister Janice arrives
on the scene she's dealt with her
tumultuous upbringing by moving West and
embracing New Age philosophies but can't
help but get drawn back into their life
Tony and Janice aren't the only soprano
siblings however there's one more a
little sister who got out and stayed out
Barbara played in a handful of episodes
by Nicole Beret Barbara lives out of
town and is rarely involved with the
soprano family business the character is
absent from seasons 3 and four then
returns for 10 episodes in the show's
last two seasons this time played by
Danielle deio even with her increased
presence in the series final run Barbara
was never a major character and her role
was by far the smallest in the family
NBC's Hannibal based on the best-selling
novels by Thomas Harris was unlike any
show on network television Baroque
gorgeous and gruesome series Creator
Brian Fuller crafted a bloody Thriller
for three seasons that was beautiful to
watch even if you were watching through
your fingers this is the nightmare that
followed him out of his dreams censored
around haunted FBI profiler Will Graham
and a psychiatrist The aerod Gourmet
Hannibal Lecter the series follows
Graham's attempts to catch various
serial killers and protect his own
fragile sanity while Lecter Works to
keep Graham and his FBI boss Jack
Crawford from discovering that he is a
brutal cannibalistic killer himself
season 2 Works in elements from Harris's
sequel Hannibal introducing meat packing
arys Margo Verger and her sadistic
incestuous brother Mason played by
Michael pit and punishes Mason for his
abuse of Margot and for his General
impoliteness by drugging him and forcing
him to mutilate and eat his own face in
season 3 Mason returns for Revenge
paralyzed from the neck down and
horribly disfigured I would like you to
begin arrangements for Dr Hannibal elor
to be eaten alive but the actor
underneath the Prosthetics is not pit
but actor Joe Anderson as pit declined
to return to the role after season 2
premiering on NBC the same year as
Hannibal with a somewhat similar premise
was the Blacklist James sper stars as
Raymond red Readington a master criminal
who's evaded capture for decades
Readington turns himself into the FBI in
exchange for immunity promising to help
the bureau track down the world's most
dangerous criminals his Blacklist but of
course there's a catch Readington will
only work with rookie profiler Elizabeth
Kean while the series has a case of the
week structure with red and Kean
bringing down one illegal operation or
another the central mystery of
Readington true identity and his
connection to Liz power the show through
10 high intrigued Seasons a major clue
to the mystery of both red and lizz's
backgrounds dropped with the
introduction of Brian Den's character
Dominic Wilkerson in season 3 as a
former KGB agent posing as a retired
systems analyst Dom has a Long messy
history with red one that somehow
intersects with Liz's own background
after a handful of appearances Through
The Years Don becomes integral to the
show's ongoing storyline in season 7 but
producers were thrown a tragic Cur ball
when Denny he passed away in April 2020
rather than rework the upcoming season
scripts the powers at B decided to
recast the role without actor Ron Reigns
who played Dom for three episodes in
season
8 sometimes a show recasts a role due to
the death of an actor but other times
it's due to the death of the show itself
that was a case with all rise the CBS
courtroom drama that premiered in 2019
in which Simone mik starred as Lola
carmichel a former prosecutor turned Los
Angeles County's newest judge I've been
in court before I know how this works
you think you know but you don't not yet
the series followed the ins and outs of
her daily case load as well as the lives
of the men and women who worked at the
courthouse her fellow judges her old
prosecutor colleagues clerks BFFs
reporters and more Lola's husband FBI
agent Robin Taylor was played for the
first two seasons by Todd Williams the
show was canceled by CBS in May 2021
several months later however it was
saved from Oblivion by the Oprah Winfrey
Network and a third and final season
aired on own in 2022 instead of asking
the cop why I was being zip tied you
asked me what I did wrong season 3 took
place a year after the the events of
season 2 which saw Lola have a baby and
lose her judgeship after defending an
innocent woman from arrest most of the
original cast returned for the final
season with the exception of Williams
who had booked the Amazon young adult
series Panic as a result actor Christian
Keys took over as Robin for season 3
each season of the Breaking Bad prequel
Better Call Saul begins with an
enigmatic black and white sequence
following the gray paranoid life of
Jimmy McGill formerly known as New
Mexico criminal lawyer salt Goodman now
living as Cinnabon manager Jean takovic
after the explosive events of the final
season of Breaking Bad starting in
season 3 however those opening scenes
coales into an ongoing story as a panic
attack puts Gene in the hospital season
4 begins with Jean's cab ride back from
the hospital where his driver has an
Albuquerque Isotopes decal on his mirror
and keeps shooting glances at his
passenger season 5 reveals that the
driver Jeff played by Don Harvey does
indeed recognize Gan as Saul but his
motivations remain unclear the sixth and
final season for goes the black and
white scenes until the final three
episodes where Jee decides not not to
run again but to confront Jeff and
neutralize him via an old-fashioned
sliping Jimmy con game for these final
episodes however Harvey was not
available due to his commitment to the
HBO series we own the city Pat Healey
stepped into the role Jeffy this is Mr
takovic call me Jean Harvey's original
take had a hint of menace while Hees was
more of a sad sack divorce living with
his mother and desperate for a taste of
the salt Goodman
lifestyle Law and Order and its
spin-offs have had no shortage of cast
turnover over the decade since its 1990
Premiere part of this is baked into the
premise of the show detectives and
attorneys come in and out on a regular
basis and the departures are explained
by transfer retirement arrest or even
death the eras of the show come to be
defined by who's running the two
separate but equally important groups in
the criminal justice system seasons 4- 6
Encompass Jill Hennessy's turn as
assistant district attorney cla concade
a search warrant with this you can't be
serious toward the end of Hennessy's run
on the show she appeared in character as
concade on 1996 episode of homicide life
on the street while it's not exactly a
Law and Order spin-off it existed in the
same television universe and
occasionally shared characters most
memorably Richard Belzer's detective
John Munch filming homicide on location
in Baltimore however meant that Hennessy
missed a few days of filming the season
6 Law and Order episode Corpus deai
luckily she had a novel solution to this
problem her identical twin sister
Jacqueline could step in his concade for
a few background courtroom
shots